Was ist gesünder, Cola oder Smoothie?
Tja, wenn ich schon so frage...
Ihr wolltet wissen: Wie gesund
oder ungesund ist Fruchtzucker?
Ich will das heute am Beispiel
cooler versus Smoothie durchgehen.
Dass Cola gesund ist, sollte
inzwischen bei jedem angekommen sind.
Je nach Marke enthält Cola
10-11 g Zucker pro 100 ml.
In einer einzigen
Standard-500ml-Colaflasche
nimmt man also
50-55 g Zucker zu sich.
Damit ist dann auch schon der
empfohlene Tageswert überschritten.
Außerdem, bei gleichen Kalorien,
macht Trinken weniger satt als Essen.
"Empty Calories" kann man das nennen.
Also einfach nur Kalorien
ohne brauchbare Nährstoffe.
Nicht dass Zucker
kein wichtiger Nährstoff wäre.
Unser Körper
braucht Zucker als Energiequelle.
Vor allem
unser Gehirn läuft auf Zucker.
Aber ein typisch
westlicher Lebensstandard
versorgt uns mit ausreichend Zucker,
v.a. über Kohlenhydrate.
Süßigkeiten und Softdrinks
sind also reines Vergnügen ohne
eine gesundheitliche Notwendigkeit.
Im Gegenteil, es ist schlecht.
Stattdessen lieber ein Smoothie.
Wer zu faul ist,
sich selbst was zu mixen,
kann sowas im Supermarkt kaufen.
Die meisten betonen,
dass hier nur Obst drin ist,
kein zusätzlicher Zucker.
Aber wozu auch, denn hier ist genauso
viel Zucker drin wie in Cola.
Bei manchen Smoothies
ist es ein bisschen weniger Zucker,
bei den meisten ist es
tatsächlich genauso viel wie in Cola.
Bei einigen sogar noch mehr,
über 13 g pro 100 l.
Aber: Der Zucker hier drin
ist doch kein Haushaltszucker,
sondern natürlicher Zucker
aus Obst und Früchten, oder?
Wenn ich schon so frag.
Haushaltszucker
heißt Saccharose oder Sucrose
und ist ein Zweifachzucker,
bestehend aus Glucose und Fructose.
Zur Hälfte besteht Haushaltszucker
also aus Glucose.
Die Bedeutung von Glucose
für unseren Stoffwechsel
habe ich in unserem Video
zu Low Carb erklärt.
Das könnt ihr euch anschauen.
Die andere Hälfte ist Fructose,
auch bekannt als Fruchtzucker.
Nur der Name Fruchtzucker
kann irreführend sein,
denn Früchte und Obst
enthalten nicht nur Fruchtzucker,
sondern eben auch
Fructose und Glucose.
Das Verhältnis
von Fructose zu Glucose
kann anders ausfallen als beim
Haushaltszucker, wo es 1:1 ist,
aber prinzipiell essen wir
mit Obst auch einfach nur Zucker.
Aber ist Fructose irgendwie besser
oder schlechter als Glucose?
Zum großen Teil
ist es einfach dasselbe.
Denn wenn wir Fructose essen,
wird sie in unserer Stoffwechsel
zu einem großen Teil
in Glucose umgewandelt.
Das heißt Fructose ist im Endeffekt
auch nichts anderes als Glucose,
zumindest zu einem großen Teil.
Was passiert
mit dem Rest der Fructose,
der nicht in Glucose
umgewandelt wird?
Hier scheiden sich die Geister.
Man kann es als Vorteil sehen,
dass nicht die gesamte Fructose
in Glucose umgewandelt wird,
denn Glucose ist das Molekül,
dass die Insulinantwort
in unserem Körper triggert
und deswegen auch
in der Entwicklung von
Diabetes Typ II eine Rolle spielt.
Allerdings
gibt es eine Menge Studien,
die einen Zusammenhang sehen
zwischen einem hohen Fructose-Konsum
und Diabetes Typ II.
Der Mediziner Robert Lustig,
wie das die Amerikaner wohl sagen,
der jede Art von Zucker
als Gift bezeichnet,
geht so weit zu behaupten,
dass Fructose
genauso schädlich sei wie Alkohol.
Denn im Gegensatz zu Glucose,
wird Fructose auch
in der Leber verstoffwechselt,
was zu einer "Nonalcoholoc
Fatty Liver" führen kann.
Also einer Alkohol-Leber
nur durch Fructose.
Man muss aber sagen,
dass du Lustig selbst nicht an diesem
Stoffwechsel-Mechanismen forscht.
Die Menschen,
die daran tatsächlich forschen,
sind da deutlich vorsichtiger.
Ob und inwieweit Fructose
eine Fettleber verursachen kann,
ist eine ernstzunehmende Sorge,
ist aber noch nicht
wissenschaftlich geklärt.
Solange wir auf weitere
Forschungsergebnisse warten,
können wir zwei Sachen mitnehmen.
Erstens: Weniger Zucker essen
ist definitiv eine gute Idee,
denn Zucker ist definitiv ungesund.
Zweitens: Hier ist
gleich viel Zucker drin.
Aber wenn hier
so viel Zucker drin ist,
warum wird Obstessen dann empfohlen?
Im Gegensatz zu Cola besteht Obst
nicht aus "leeren Kalorien".
Wir haben viele Vitamine, Mineralien,
Folsäure, Ballaststoffe...
Und bei Smoothies?
Wenn ihr das nächste Mal
im Supermarkt seid,
schaut auf die Inhaltsstoffe.
In der Regel bestehen die nicht
zu 100% aus Vollobst oder Vollfrucht,
sondern enthalten Fruchtsäfte.
Deswegen trinken sich
diese Smoothies auch so smooth,
weil da eben keine Ballaststoffe,
keine Zellulosefasern usw. drin sind.
Natürlich sind da
noch die Vitamine usw. drin,
aber wir haben bei Saft
eine deutlich höhere Zuckerdichte
als wenn ihr
dasselbe Obst essen würdet.
Während ihr also so nen Smoothie
einfach so runtertrinkt,
würde euch dieselbe Menge Obst
definitiv satter machen.
Da ihr so viel Zucker
auf einmal zu euch nehmt,
kann das die positiven
Vitamin-Effekte negativ kompensieren.
Ein bisschen,
als würdet ihr eine Multivitamin-
tablette mit Cola trinken.
Aber nicht
alle Smoothies sind schlecht.
Smoothies selbst machen
ist deutlich besser.
Also keinen Saft pressen,
sondern das volle Obst
einfach nur pürieren, wie es ist,
mit Schale, Kernen, allem drum und
dran, wie ihr es auch essen würdet
und gegebenenfalls
mit Wasser verdünnen.
Auch grüne Smoothies
sind kein verkehrter Trend,
wenn ihr sie selbst macht.
Weil ihr dadurch Ballaststoffe
mit reinbringt ohne Zucker.
Wenn man das richtige Rezept hat,
schmeckt es noch nicht mal so grün,
wie man sich
das vielleicht vorstellt.
In der Endcard
hab ich mein Lieblings-
Green-Smoothie-Rezept für euch.
Aber nichts ist gesünder, als
Obst einfach ganz normal zu essen.
Erstens: Wie am Anfang schon gesagt,
die Form des Essens
hat einen Einfluss
auf unser Sättigungsempfinden.
Zweitens: Trinken
geht auch schneller als Essen.
Dadurch nehmen wir dieselben Kalorien
in ner kürzeren Zeit
auf einmal zu uns,
sodass unser Blutzuckerspiegel
auch schneller, schlagartiger steigt.
Also möglichst viel Wasser trinken
und die Kalorien möglichst
über festes Essen zu sich nach.
Aber deswegen jetzt selbstgemachte
Smoothies zu verteufeln,
ist auch zu viel des Guten.
Mir persönlich macht ein Smoothie
manchmal einfach mehr Spaß
als Obst zu essen und kann
ne Motivation sein an Tagen,
wo ich oft gar kein Essen würde.
Deswegen in der Endcard
ein Green-Smoothie-Rezept für euch.
Wenn ihr noch Themen-Vorschläge habt,
schreibt sie gerne in Kommentare.
Bis nächsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Freunde der Sonne, ihr braucht
eine reife Banane, einen Apfel,
ne Viertel Zitrone, oder ne halbe, je
nachdem, wie sauer ihr es gerne mögt,
und ne Handvoll Babyspinat.
Wenn ihr Anfänger seid, achtet
darauf, dass es Babyspinat ist.
Normaler Spinat ist was
für advcanced green smoothier,
Smoothie-Freunde.
Wasser, je nachdem, wie dick
oder dünn ihr es gerne hättet,
in den Mixer. Und fertig.
Falls ihr das Zuhause ausprobiert,
ich finde dieser Smoothie
ist absolut instagramable.
Tagt mich gerne.
@maithink bin ich auf Instagram.
Und vielen herzlichen Dank
an alle Freunde der Sonne,
die uns unterstützt haben
beim Publikumsvotum
für den Grimme-Online-Award.
Morgen, also wenn dieses Video
rauskommt, dann morgen,
ist die Preisverleihung.
Den Link zum Livestream
der Preisverleihung
gibt es in der Videobeschreibung.
Drückt uns die Daumen.